foreign
piece that I published this week in
Natural Selections in which one of the
things I was talking about
which we also talked about in our
private q a last week was why it seems
to be okay uh to dress up in what I'm
now calling Woman face uh either as a
you know drag or in its uh more
egregious form trans
um when it's a trans rights activist as
opposed to you know someone who is
really deeply genders for it and
absolutely needs this in order to feel
like they can live their best life which
is a very tiny number of people
um whereas uh the world I would argue
correctly says actually blackface not so
cool uh and you know it's not culturally
appropriation as some have have said
it's really it's phenotypic mimicry and
it's generally phenotypic mimicry with
an eye towards mockery and that's what
is phenotypic mockery is what it is is
what blackface is and frankly I would
argue so you know Woman face although
many would say oh it's not mockery well
you see these exaggerated makeup
especially on on drag queens and it
looks like it looks like mockery at
least it feels that way to myself and
many other women who see who see people
in Drag and in in Trends outfits
um
I went looking uh I one of the places
one of the
regions of the internet I have not here
to for explored was what happens to the
interface of uh drag queens and
blackface
some dangerous clicks involved in that
investigation dangerous clicks and uh
interestingly I didn't find anything
super modern everything was from a few
years ago but there are a number of
these stories and I just want to you
know put out their one one of of them uh
in which uh let's see this is uh
well in in all of the cases there is
some drag queens who are shocked at the
racism one of their members in which you
know he a white man does a character as
a black woman and
um you know I don't find these
characters funny at all for all the
reasons but you know some people
apparently do
um but what's strange to me is the
outrage the complete lack of
self-awareness in which the drag queens
are saying things like and here's a
direct quote from one of these stories
the whole concept of blackface being an
art form or being entertainment to me it
doesn't make sense at all that anyone
would think it's okay
said Alfonso King who performs drag
under the name Jade Electra
the whole concept let's just change
blackface to Woman face the whole
concept of Woman face being an art
former being entertainment to me it
doesn't make sense at all that anyone
would think that's okay
now maybe the difference is that some
number of people who are doing drag as a
form of entertainment will say I'm
celebrating woman
well it doesn't read that way to a lot
of us and I don't think almost anyone
who goes out in blackface thinks or
would even claim that they're
celebrating Blackness I think that that
is going to be one distinction that
people will make but it lives as a
inconsistency that I now can't unsee
that you have people who are so embedded
in what they're calling an art form of
adopting the the looks and the artifacts
of the opposite sex
and doing so without any regard for how
that will be regarded by the opposite
sex who can stand up and say you must be
fired you must stop doing that that's
not allowed when it's about adopting a
phenotypic indicator of a race that
they're not it is at the very least in
consistency I read it as hypocrisy and I
re I also read it as something that you
know other people have have tried to
engage this uh you know this whole
concept of trans racialism right like
you you can't be transracial
except that and I make this point in the
work hypocrisies piece you know sex is
actually real and ancient and binary and
for at least 500 million years and
probably closer to one to two billion
years we have been in a lineage that has
been reproducing sexually with two and
only two Sexes and every single human
being who is who is among your ancestors
has been either male or female that is
true whereas race to the extent that it
has biological reality is much more
muddled those those borders are muddled
there is no pure anything in race
because we are sexually reproducing like
I mean this is actually one of the weird
points here right like because we are
sexually reproducing and have been
forever basically yeah not quite but
almost forever there is no pure race
that's a fiction that that is the
fantasists uh you know who are racist
who would tell you that there is purity
of race so there may be people who are
all from you know Scotland and all of
their ancestors from time immemorial but
nowhere close to 500 million years have
been you know Scottish uh and there may
be people who are you know similarly
Lithuanian or you know whatever but
every single new person is the result of
sexual reproduction and therefore
there's no Purity there and so if
transracialism isn't a thing
transsexualism really is not
all right there's a bunch there yeah I
think there are a couple things that
need highlighting one I think you're the
point you're making can be well
encapsulated by saying can we is there a
meaningful distinction to be drawn
between a Minstrel show and a drag show
I heard menstrual menstrual show not a
thing thankfully Minstrel show yeah the
drag show yeah menstrual
Minstrel show there you go and a drag
show and I would argue
there are distinctions you could draw
but
those distinctions are subtle at best
and what they tell you is actually
you should sit down for this
um actually neither of these things can
be a Minstrel show and a drag show
put the shows aside you can't rule out
blackface right why because the
character of Roger needs to do a
Minstrel show at his daughter's wedding
right on Mad Men on Madden you dropped
the lead there so you've got a character
a white man on the show Mad Men Who
behaving in a racist way the actor is
allowed to put on blackface to play the
character who was being abominable thank
you for filling in all of that yes not
sure it's not actually sufficient to get
most people there right likewise yes
Monty Python has to be able
to
um
do Preposterous caricatures of women
lumberjacks no it's not the Lumberjack
it is is all of the characters where the
Monty Python dudes
um you know
he's not the Messiah he's a very naughty
boy that thing right because Brian's
mother right Brian's mother for example
I hitting the Life of Brian yes right so
the point is that there's nothing
offensive in my opinion yes about the
Monty Python thing and in fact it is
mocking itself in its own way the
ridiculous portrayals of female are so
silly yes right that that's part of the
comedy
the importance of blackface to the
character of Roger in Mad Men in Mad Men
mind you
um the importance of that character's uh
cringy uh Minstrel show at his
daughter's wedding is fundamental to the
plot yeah yeah so really just daughter's
wedding I believe so I don't I don't
remember that part but anyway it was but
anyway point is
in a civilized society right it is fine
to make a rule like uh blackface is not
cool because it isn't yeah right that
does not mean there there are no edge
cases in which you have to allow it
right or where it's important yes right
um and likewise last week we talked
about
um you know Victor Victoria
Mrs Doubtfire I believe we'll talk about
that in their private q a oh is that
private anyway so those those examples
plus money
plus Monty Python those examples all are
cases in which there's a very strong
defense to be made of something which in
another in another context uh
would be troubling
I don't know exactly what to think about
drag shows I don't know that they're
identical to Minstrel shows and that we
will come to understand that or not but
I do I I I think never haven't been to
either yeah that uh the people engaging
in the black face of the woman face will
have different stories to tell that the
minstrel shows which aren't a thing
anymore yeah
um from the let's call it the 1920s
uh had people donning blackface knowing
that they were proudly making fun of
black people and that drag shows in you
know 100 years later and it's not a fair
comparison because it's 100 years later
but that at this point anyway drag shows
um I think it is going to be the rare
drag performer who will say of course
I'm making fun of women it's not going
to be the cover story right so there's
there's an important distinction there
but one which you know but one which we
have to try to
um correct for the difference in time
between when they're happening I
actually think it's almost the opposite
thing that's that's bugging you and that
has you focused on this
I do think that a drag show
I've never been to one either yeah a
drag show from 30 years ago
involves men who do have a strong
affinity for
femaleness who do aspire to it in some
sense it's autogonophiles right many are
fair enough but the point is that's very
different than mocking
all right and I think what you're
responding to is that as trans activism
has become hostile to women right this
has gone from a weird aspiration a nice
fetish a niche fetish but nonetheless a
something that is desirous enough of
being woman that it will you know Play
Act Right to being a threat to women in
declaring that this is synonymous with
being a woman right and that that is
actually the thing is it's gone and the
minstrel shows were never that they were
never as far as I know they were never
what you were performing show from 30
years ago would have been right exactly
and yeah that may be right yeah and I
there's one other distinction I want to
draw
for our entire lives people have often
equated racism and sexism and therefore
the fights against them right this was a
mistake they are not symmetrical right
you've got two different types of
Oppression and disadvantage right one of
them is more pernicious than the other
they may be both terribly frustrating
but
it makes perfect evolutionary sense
for one lineage
to oppress another lineage
to drive another lineage to Extinction
whatever perfect evolutionary sense
well-being and Abomination it's an
Abomination but the point is it is not
illogical it is immoral but not
illogical
this has never been what went on between
males and females because males and
females share a lineage and every
individual effectively is arbitrarily
cast into one of these roles at the
point the zygote has formed and you the
rest of the genes in the genome don't
know whether they're going to live out
this life male or female and so the
point is the idea that male genes gang
up on female genes doesn't make any
sense because most of the genes spend
half their time as each one so
male individuals will try to control the
behavior and placement of female
individuals as has happened forever but
male genes ganging up on female genes
except with regard to something like
genomic imprinting on the fetus where uh
just to you know do a little David Hague
style thing very very briefly here
in a situation in which a mother a
pregnant woman is pregnant with a man
who may not be the father of her future
children
she has an interest in having a child
who is as healthy as possible but also
retaining her ability to have future
children and so we have as humans a a
problem a trade-off where we want our
kids to be born as late as possible as
fully cooked as possible so they are
maximally likely to survive but we have
gigantic heads and for women to have
pelvises as wide as would be optimal for
the birth to be safe would make women
very very unstable basically and so
birth childbirth is not just painful but
quite dangerous precisely because
there's a trade-off between size of the
child's head at Birth and you know how
fully cooked it is and therefore How
likely it is to survive and so a woman
who is pregnant simultaneously wants
that child to survive but also wants to
be able to still be reproductively
capable for future children and so the
genes in the fetus that were inherited
from her some of them are more likely to
tend towards a slightly smaller head
size on birth
so that she is able to not just take
care of that child but future children
whereas and that's and those genes are
so called imprinted
um so the the fetal the fetus has genes
that are imprinted from mother
um that um it inherited he or she
inherited from other and those that are
paternally inherited that are um that
are imprinted from Dad I'm not sure I'm
saying that exactly the right way
imprinted from Dad but um the dad's
genes especially in a polygenous society
are more likely to drive the head of
that child to be larger on birth so that
the child is more fully formed on birth
but even in that case
the male who loves him and leaves them
yeah has an interest in that female
surviving to raise the offsprings it's
very unlikely to survive if she doesn't
absolutely but this is but I mean this
is not just theoretical work right like
hey let's demonstrate this is you know
work David Hague Harvard in the 90s I
think right and it's been you know
followed through with a lot more that
we're not going to go into now but
um it is known that genomic imprinting
is true and that maternally imprinted
genes and paternally imprinted genes are
in disagreement in this one small way in
um with regard to for instance the
degree to which the child is is
um is fully cooked on birth they have a
limited not being the technical term
they have a limited disagreement and the
point in this context the point is that
disagreement is not limited between
lineages which we wrongly call races but
nonetheless yes the distinction between
race on Race oppression and
sex on sex oppression is no comparison
at all they're very different and the
fact is individual women may suffer from
the fact that power is very
asymmetrically distributed in
Civilization
less so but it has been very
asymmetically distributed but there are
women at every strata right at every
level of well-being and
the distinction between that and what
happens in races is a major one so if
there is you know the argument here has
been there might be some distinction
between a Minstrel show and a drag show
but it's awfully hard to explain exactly
what it's based on and even this
fundamental difference between race and
sex oppression does not suggest an
obvious distinction other than the one
we've talked about where
um
a drag show
could be something other than mockery it
could be aspiration and I don't think
Minstrel shows ever are yes I agree
[Music]